He agreed to talk to me after giving like some really bad review
of one of my streams or some commentary I made on Willie. He
agreed to talk to me and then he refused to talk to me after
that. That that frustrated me when he did that, right? Cuz he
was like he he made a whole bunch of negative commentary and
then I was like, "Oh, do you want to talk?" And he was like,
"Yeah, I'll come on and talk." And then he like told uh Smaggle
that he'd come on and talk. And then he was like, "Actually,
no, I'm not going to come on and talk." And no, I don't want
to talk to at all anymore. And I think that's mostly just proximity
to uh Queen of some other people. I I think that had nothing
to do with me. It just mostly had to do with being like proximal
to Quean and stuff when Quean was going off about some of the
things he said. What did Queman do? Uh Quimman's all of Nicholas's
friends one by one. What does that I told Nick that the first
time I ever met him and I told him that pretty much every time
I met him after that. There's nothing he can do about it. What
friends and how is he
Uh because they can't handle uh they can't handle criticism.
I'll show that tweet before we go into the Chud stuff. I think
I went and grabbed a time stamp here. I'll just go show you I'll
go show you the tweet. I threw this out. Uh, wow. I had no idea.
Uh, Chud had become such a virulent anti-semite. And then there's
some stuff about Hassan. And I threw my donation link in here.
I don't want to I don't want to look at this. Okay. You check
from the ATL's in the mail, sir. Yeah. I trust me. I'm going
to let this one hang out here for a bit. But uh we'll go over
the I don't want to click on the clip because then I'm going
to actually spoil the clip and I don't want to do that. I don't
want to spoil the clip for you guys. Okay. I think it's like
2 minutes or something. All right. It's like 2 minutes or something.
Okay. All right. Grab it right here. I think this is it. I think
this is it. It's because there's like barely anything happening
at the moment. Oh, Chud. Yeah. So Chud was watching some Cameron
F305 stuff with these guys and he was like, "The only reason
I care about this is cuz nothing's going on." And then he rants
about some of the stuff that is going on. The drama ecosystem
is as dry as the Sahara unless you're willing to do the 20th
stream sucking off Ethan Klein. Yes, I'm talking about you, Nicholas
Dioro. Okay. Unless you Oh, wait. I don't have Oh my god. I didn't
have it ready. Hold on. Hold on. I have a Oh [__]
Oh [__] That's the one Nick loves. That's the one
Nick loves. Yes. The 20th stream in a row. Sucking off Ethan
Klein. I'm talking to you, Nicholas Dori. Okay. All right. I
guess I You know what? I guess we're going to stream going, "Oh,
isn't Ethan correct about everything?" And the song's totally
wrong. Unless you're willing to do that, it's dry as the Tahara
out there, bro. It is not. There's nothing happening. It is so
boring, dude. I'm okay. Okay, that's not so bad, right? That's
not so bad. That That's forgivable. That can that we can pause
right there and Chud can walk away from this and no harm, no
foul. It happens. Okay, it happens. So uninspired every single
day when I wake up and I think, right, what is Ed to talk about
today? What? We love the ADL, guys, don't we? Yeah, the ADL.
We do. We do not love the ADL. What do I say when Jonathan Greenblack
comes on screen, guys? What do I say? Hold on. Hold on. I don't
have my I don't have my soundboards lined up well at all.
Every time Jonathan Greenblat appears on my screen.
Get him off. Get him out of here. Get him out. You Jonathan Greenblat.
You are the worst.
Inspired every single day when I wake up and I think right what
is Ed to talk about today? What? We love the ADL guys, don't
we? Yeah. The ADL are absolutely correct about everything, aren't
they? All of a sudden now because we're against Assan and we
want to suck Ethan's The ADL apparently are great instinct. The
ADL [__] suck, bro. The ADL [__] suck.
The Now do do we have to go over like why Chud thinks this? We
all know the ADL sucks, right? The ADL are the people who got
like all of the right-wingers deplatformed to begin with. The
ADL basically push censorship everywhere on the internet. They
are the one of the biggest forces for censorship and for like
over to policing on platforms anywhere on the internet. And they
will go after anti-semitism, but they'll push on all kinds of
levers. It's anti-semitism is a chief concern, but it's all kinds
of things. And there are lots of cases where where they're going
after like bad people. They're going after outright anti-semites.
But there are cases where they're not doing that, too. And they
blur the lines. and they they're happy to blur the lines because
blurring the lines if they can find more anti-semitism then they
can find more people who are who can get like blessed by the
ADL right so if you saw when Elon Musk got in all of his troubles
with advertisers he was talking to the ADL first he said the
ADL and then he was talking to playing nice with the ADL and
trying to like get back on the same page with them right I'm
confused why hasn't he just called Destiny fat and a log Amran's
husband well not all of us are that talented mock rabbit okay
you're in a unique place unique time a unique place Okay. Okay.
All right. Yes. That's Hey, we all get through trying times in
our own way. All right. Don't mock my coping mechanism. Mock
rabbit. What the [__] I'm just getting through things
the best way I know how, which is finding somebody that I find
amusing and then farming forever and ever and ever. Amen. Okay.
What? We'll just do it forever. And Nick Nick is special. Okay.
Nick Lee is special in terms of being like a kind of loc. And
I've we do have to get to some of that stuff later tonight and
we will. All right. Anyway, the ADL are by far like perhaps the
most sensorious organization that exists on the internet. They
will always push proensorship stuff. And the way it happens is
a lot of the stuff that they'll push for the sake of anti-semitism
will end up because people don't want to be called um racist
or they don't want to, you know, put into place some of these
exceptional exceptionalism rules. Jew Jewish exceptionalism rules.
Yeah. They'll end up like trying to take a lot of this stuff
and and put it into every group or or apply things to every group.
They'll try to make rules that work for everybody. But if you
look at like how the ADL pushes this, they just end up pushing
everybody into a more sensorious place all the time. So the fear
of the Iron Fist. I thought we were going to tell Can we call
Can we get to the place where we can finally just call Nicholas
Doro's stomach what we all know it is? It is the Iron Dome. Okay.
In terms of internet commentary, Nicholas's stomach is the Iron
Dome. If you get in his belly, okay, like Ethan Klein has, you
can you can you face no wrath, okay? He'll protect you from everything.
The Iron Dome protects us from all. Okay, apparently you're a
great entity. The ADL suck, bro. The ADL suck. The ADL are terrible.
Okay, this idea that Ethan is this. Is he crying that I called
him bad again? I believe he is, Kelly. I believe he went after
you again because Nicholas instead of Nicholas just going after
who he's actually mad at. He wants to take shots at Kelly Jean.
That is his that's apparently the person he can take safe shots
at or me but probably Kelly Jean. Okay. Sensible operator that
is like doing is so based in giga challenge. It's not true. It's
not true. Ethan has gone insane and people aren't talking about
it. Dude, it's so annoying, dude. Uh-oh. Hold on. I did not I
didn't pick up that little bit of anti. Did he just insist that
Ethan Klein's mental state is not perfect? Did this anti-Semitic
piece of just suggest that Ethan Klein isn't operating with his
full mental faculties? I Okay, I totally disavow that Ethan Klein
is 100%. He is He's got a clear look at this. He is operating
with a clear mind. There is nothing wrong with Ethan Klein. I
don't know what this guy just said. Totally disavow everything
he just put on the screen here. Totally disavow it. Ethan Klein
is thinking totally correctly when he sues random bread tubers
for whatever he can. He's thinking totally correctly, okay, at
all times. He's obviously fine. I don't know what we're Why are
we pretending otherwise? Tonight, Ethan is this, you know, voice
of reason. He's the voice of reason who is like, you know, oh
yeah, he's so correct and oh, he got skulls sent to his house
and oh, the CPS school. Yeah. Well, what are you saying? That
that's not a terrible thing, Chad. Are you saying that that doesn't
mean that he should be upset? Obviously, he should be upset.
What? Can he not be upset about that? The answer, sorry, I don't
know where I'm going with this, but the answer to that is, of
course, he can be upset. It just doesn't mean he should sue anybody.
That stuff all, but can we stop pretending like he's not acting
like a total insane freak, bro? Oh my god. I'm going to lose
it, dude.
Okay. Chad forgot about the the Nazi sword, actually. Okay, that's
wonderful. But how do I make Chud forgot? Chad wouldn't be saying
this. He wouldn't be crashing out like this if he just remembered
that they also used a Nazi sword. sword. I think if he could
just remember the Nazi sword, I think Chud would calm down. He'd
realize that that Ethan is correct. Money off depressed people.
Ehd made it in somehow. I've let it out. I've let it out. I've
let it out. That's wonderful. But how do I make money off depressed
people? Jud's falling down
Thank you for the super chat, Freddy. Thank for the $20. And
thank you again for the $10. That's wonderful. But how do I make
money off depressed people? Gringle became a member of celebration
15 months.
It's just banter. Ethan's lost his mind. Guys, it's just banter,
guys. Guys, it's just banter. He's totally lost, bro. It's just
banter. It's just banter, guys. It's just banter.
Sounds like you really want to talk about Ethan and her Samch.
I don't want to talk about it cuz I'm bored of it. That's so
boring, dude. I've been covering that for ages. I've covered
it. I've covered it since before you realized. But how do I make
money after press people? Get back to the content. It's a sure.
Oh, is he going to go? I don't I don't know if I saw any more
of this. By the way, that was the uh that was the clip or whatever.
The old 80th thing. That was a pretty good British accent. No,
that was just me impersonating something I've heard Chud say
completely, so it sounds like I can do a British accent. I was
just totally fooling you there. I cannot do one at all. And also,
it's all rooted in this Israel Palestine analysis you got to
do that most people aren't capable of doing, by the way. Right.
I covered politics for a long time. I'm not capable of getting
into the weeds with Israel Palestine. I don't know the ins and
outs of it to talk about it. And you get What did Fatty say about
me? Uh, do we have a screenshot of whatever Nick made some side
comment about Kelly somewhere? I forget. Come along and they
they talk about it at anybody's got the link clue. And yet they're
listened to without question. It's so frustrating, bro. It's
such a frustrating situation. Oh my god. Dude, you're making
me can't stop. I can't stop now. I literally can't stop, bro.
Okay, that's wonderful. But how do I make money off depressed
people? RSC owns you. Yeah, okay, sure. They're owning me super
hard with their gay little stream where they're shaving their
head for cash. Whatever. I don't care anymore, bro.
Yell about Noox Taki now, bro. Dude, this is the other problem
as well with all this, right? You've now got the most wretched,
wicked freaks of the space like Nux, Taku, Asang God. Oh, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did Nicholas, did Nicholas go on
a rant about Chud. I didn't see any of this. Oh, I just thought
there was just this one clip. Uh-oh. I just got sent like a logs
of Nicholas like talking about this stream. Oh, wait. This went
like deeper than I thought it went. Uh-oh. Does Chud not realize
that Nicholas like basically made half of that stream? Is Chud
really going to go against Mr. Deorio? Mr. Oreos. Okay. Yeah.
No, I got the Kelly I got the Kelly thing in here. Okay. Is this
in Dude, beautiful. Beautiful. Oh my god. Thank you so much.
Okay. Jumping on this as well. They're jumping on this situation
too with their own narratives and spinning their own tails about
this cuz they want to throw Trump's left, right, and center.
And by the way, by the way, I'll just tell you most people can
put this together, okay? I know a lot of people in my community
try to say that this is like all unfortunately you miss all of
the time off stream where we all sit in the same group call going
over these things and it is like all of us complaining about
the same thing. Okay, there's this one person who's a little
too irritated to keep it to themselves. It's this kid over here.
Okay, people are, you know, making the same points that they're
make. Dude, it is so obnoxious and annoying and irritating. I
know, guys. I I'm going to fight for the future of my country.
I think I think America's in a really fascist place, okay? And
nowhere is that more clear than in Hassan [__] just
spewing anti-semitic filth all over the twitch.tv platform. Okay?
And in that fight joining me is Teone, Trump dick suck. Asmin
Gold, Trump dick suck. Nuaku, Trump dick suck. Uh, you know what?
It's fine. I Yeah, I totally think Trump's a problem. Guys, can
I get a quick poll of the people who are shoulder-to-shoulder
with me? Is Trump a Is Trump a problem right now? Trump's a problem,
right? I think No. You think Trump's good? You think Trump's
awesome? Okay. As Gold thinks Trump's awesome. Nucks, what do
you Oh, Dan Saltman. Yeah, I mean, Dan's over there. Listen,
if it comes down to if I have to pick somebody that I want to,
you know, if I have to pick somebody who has to exist in the
political zeitgeist between
Noxaku, Asminold, Tekone, and Hassan, I'm picking Hassan. I'm
sorry. I will just pick Hassan. I will take Hassan over those
Trump suckers. I will every single day of the week. I'll take
them if if it's if it's between the two. Okay. And I'm sick of
it. I'm sick of the whole thing. Okay, that's wonderful. But
how do I make money off depressed people? Para, we love to hear
an honest Irish muddy with some realis to say. I've been waiting
for this one my whole life. On God, we made it. Total fat neck.
I am obsessed. I am deranged. I am unhinged. That's a That's
a Styo donation. Of course.
Thank you, Silo, for the $20. The reality is that there is an
obsession. There is this obsessive focus is bad. Hassan is bad.
Assan is Will will he say it? Will he say the line? Will he say
the line? Have we soped this into the zeitgeist? Okay. Hassan
is bad on Hassan.
Okay, that's wonderful. But how's a video people? We love Hassan.
All right. Listen, Hassan is bad, but Hassan is bad, but he's
an idiot lefty streamer, but in the in the purposes of pursuing
Assan,
we've all become this absurd. Thank you for the stream. Anything
that's against Assan is good now. That's what it's become. Anything
that is against Assan is good now. Including the ADL, bro. The
ADL are like the [__] the heart of cancel culture,
right? Those J boys jump off the chain. Okay, that's I think
it's off the porch. I think it's they really hopping off the
porch. Am I crazy? I think he might have might have that one
up, but it's okay. Let him cook. Let him cook people. They jump
off the chain to shut down whatever conversation they can, right?
They literally justify some of the anti-semitic narratives that
exist by super hardcore counseling people that say the wrong
thing about Israel. Talk to Prime K anymore. He feeling lonely
man. And yet now all of a sudden, dude, I saw a some stardust
clip, right? And Froggen, the stupid fat wench. I know. Oh, please.
Does anybody have Just real quick, I'll pull up the uh the clips
here. Does anybody have the Yeah, I got all these. Uh, yeah,
I got all these, Ri. But, um, thank you. Thank you. Does anybody
have the Stardust clip where she's watching the Frogan thing
and Froggen's like, "The ADL sucks." and and Stardust says something
to the like something almost equivalent to I can't remember precisely
but it's like oh so we just jq in the open now it's like
what saying the ADL sucks is not saying it's not the same thing
at all what no we've all every single like centrist sort of free
speech person on the entire internet has hated the ADL for their
entire life okay the ADL's just always sucked on Kelly we'll
get there we will get there Kelly I promise you. We'll get there.
Like Frogan, right? But she said something about the ADL negative
and Stardust was there acting like it was anti-Semitic to criticize
the
ADL absolute low IQ weighing in the clip
right somebody get me the stardust clip please for the love of
God I need the stardust clip and and claiming that criticizing
the ADL is anti-semitic meon about stream some Fortnite think
you can give me a challenge now I'm sure I'm certain certain
that Frogan has got some sort of anti-semitic going on, right?
I don't like Froggen, but obviously what a concept. The ADL is
not automatically good because it's siding with Ethan at the
moment, right? The ADL is a terrible organization and they've
repeatedly been criticized for their anti-free speech perspectives,
but now they're getting sucked up because they're on the right
side apparent. Dude, it's so deranged, bro. It's so deranged.
It's so deranged. Okay, dude. I need Uh oh. Uh oh. Uh oh. Uh
hold on. All message. I judge just realized, okay, his bank account's
getting dangerous. His hopes of owning a a piece of property,
okay, of owning a home are getting further and further in the
rearview mirror as he continues this rant. Okay, Chut is like
seeing his home disappear before his eyes. He was like, "Oh,
3% interest rate, 4% interest rate." Now he's looking at like
8%. He's like, "Okay, I got to cut this. Okay, before we hit
double digits, I got to cut this rant. Cut it off. Get it out.
Jesus. People don't control the banks, by the way. That's a joke.
That's a joke. This is a little rhetorical flourish. It's a joke.
None of us take it seriously. Okay. We don't believe that. Actually,
we don't believe it. We don't believe it. I don't watch Stardust.
There's a clip that was floating around that I saw. There's a
clip that's floating around. Kelly, we're getting to the part
where we looked at the Keep going for another 15 to 20 minutes.
I've got nothing more to say. Yeah, we can. We fine. We'll make
a segment out of it. Fine. We'll make out of It would be it'
be good content, I'm sure. I'm just so sick of it, bro. I'm so
sick of it. I look around me and all it is is people throwing
Ethan at every turn. No, no critical scrutiny of him. Nicholas,
but you are so real for this. Him seal clapping at Cameron's
blatant attempt to butter him up made me want to do the You see
DK in chat? I did not see DK in chat. What was DK saying in chat?
These rants and chat banter are the reason I spend more money
on donating to you than I did on hard drugs. Thank you for the
super chats. Thank you. There's nothing wrong with milking the
drama. What I've got a problem with, what I've got a problem
with, pull up a dario vod and see what he has to say about it's
an endless commentary that Ethan is correct and Assan is wrong.
Shut the real goat. That's the thing that's frustrating. That's
the thing that I find annoying. You know, it's like there's no
critical scrutiny there whatsoever. That's the issue. That's
the issue that I've seen floating about. You keep this going
for 15 minutes so we can make a segment out of it. And Chud says,
"Yeah, oh yeah, that just happened." You know, where's the fairness?
I I like to try and be fair when I talk about stuff. Where's
the fairness, bro? Where's the fairness? Now, hold on. You don't
always have to be fair. Sometimes you can just hate somebody.
It's not like uh it's not like a lot of people are super fair
when they evaluate Stardust content. Okay. Well, maybe they are.
Maybe that's a bad example. I should pick somebody's content
I actually watch. Hold on. Okay, just hit me with it. Thank you.
This is the clip right here. This is the clip right here. Okay.
We'll see. Okay, I'm going to I'm going to try to I'm going to
try to steal man whatever Stardust says here. Okay, I'll I'll
attempt it. I will attempt it. Give me a second. Say that you
think me being in the Idubbbz video is what's going to cause
this harassment. When in reality, it's you, Ethan. You're acting
like you haven't spent the last year and a half doing everything
in your power to push people to bully and harass me, including
weaponizing propaganda organizations such as the ADL to get me
banned off Twitch because I made a joke. Propaganda organizations
like the ADL? Okay. Well, are you saying people like do propaganda
like like they control the media somehow? Is that about you not
being Okay, that is what she's going to say. Weaponizing propaganda
organizations such as the ADL.
Wow. Wow.
Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
Oh my [__] god. What the [__] dude? F.
Oh my god. Omg. Oh my
Omg. Omg. I'm going to [__] lose my mind. What is
going on? Are we just jQuing on main now? What's going on? Oh
my god.
JQuing on main now. Boy, I'm so lucky that Sardos does not watch
any of my streams cuz if this was jQuing on
holy, she would lose it if she ever watched me talk to Quean
for more than 30 seconds. Okay. I I think I do I think I do more
anti-semitism to Quan on like a minute-by-minute basis than whatever
Frogan just did right there. Okay. Uh people would not like that.
But I also support Israel. So that's my get out of jail free
card. Okay. We're on we're on the BAP train. Okay. As long as
we support Israel, they'll they'll let you get away with it.
You can make your little jokes, but you just have to be an Israel
supporter, okay? You got a friend, so it's okay. Also, you're
usually funny. That's up for debate, Salivation. Okay. Some people
Some people do not believe that. Some people do not find it funny.
Anyway, that was the clip Chud was referencing the the jQuing
on. Oh my god. Oh my god. Yeah, I know. I know. We're on the
tweet. Porter Beller, someone posted this clip elsewhere. I downloaded
so you can watch it. Watch me buffer in real time. So, like you
could you could make the argument, I guess, that saying that
the ADL is a propaganda organization with like no backing to
it, like no no understanding of like what they've done. Uh, you
you could say that that's like weird to call it propaganda. You
could say that. I Okay, Kelly keeps bothering me. I said that
there was a Kelly reference coming up and Kelly's messaged me
like a hundred times. I'll just join the Discord with her or
something. You know what? Actually, I'll just Kelly, I want to
get your genuine reaction. So, give me a second and we'll go
over the Nicholas stuff in just a minute, okay? I promise I'll
just I'll just join the Discord. Hold on. I'll just join the
Discord and you can hop in. Uh there I am. I've hopped in. Hello.
If you want to join up or something, give me two seconds here.
Okay, I can unmute now. Jesus Christ. Okay, we'll get to it.
Kelly, I promise. I promise. Let me finish the starter clip.
Stop it. JQing on. She's jQuing on Maine. She's doing it. She's
doing it. It couldn't be because it was objectively anti Kelly
have nothing better to do. Kelly is watching the stream after
she gets home from a long day of hanging out with her friends.
Luke recluse. Okay, do not mock Kelly for being a fan of the
stream. You don't you have something better to do? Why don't
you get the out of here? He's medicic. Oh my god. Oh my god.
But don't actually I appreciate every viewer. Okay. Thank you
for being here, Lucloose. Not a dog whistle. It's a fogghorn.
What was she thinking? What was she thinking? Oh my god. Oh my
god. Oh my god. What is going on? Oh my god. Oh my god. Okay.
Yeah. I don't I Okay. I I sometimes, dude, I sometimes get really
worried about the streamer thing and then I watch clips of other
streamers. Usually I only watch like streamers I really really
like and then I'll like hold myself up in comparison. I'll be
like, "I'm not doing well enough. I'm like not doing good enough."
Okay. And then I watch like other streamers and I'm like, "Oh,
no. I'll make it. I'll be okay. I'll be I'll be all right. We
can make it. We can do it. I believe." Hold on. We need to keep
watching. I'm down tired. Oh, well, you don't have to come on
if you don't want to. It's okay. I don't know why you didn't
just link me whatever it is, cuz I knew it wouldn't be 5 minutes.
Okay, it's just one comment. But now, you can't say anything
in here, okay? You can't spoil for other people. I'll just link
it. So, it was just one comment. Why couldn't you have done this
20 minutes ago? I don't Okay, don't say it. Don't say it cuz
it was It's a whole segment, Kelly. I just I wanted to get you
in here so you can comment when you were back. I even know what
the text of that is. Yeah, I don't know. Well, we'll go through
it in a little bit. Sorry. I need to finish this clip really
quick if you want to hop in. I'm downloading this video. I have
to download this video. I cannot believe it's real. I can't believe
she left it up. She left it up. She left up the video. She left
it up. It still exists. It's public. It's public. The video is
public. It's still on. I had to download this right now. Oh my
god. I'm downloading this video. I can't. There's no way. There's
no How How is she like Oh my god. I can't believe Frogan called
the ADL a propaganda organization and then she just left the
video up. I'm downloading it. There's no way she'll leave it
up. I What is What does Stardust think is going to happen? The
ADL's going to come along and get it taken down or what are we
doing? The purpose of this random Star Dust clip. I don't get
it. Uh well, if you were watching the stream previously, Kelly,
you would get it cuz it's in the context of Chudlogic mentioned
it in the middle of his incredibly anti-semitic rant from earlier.
So, every time Stardust mentioned that you have to go watch Stardust.
Uh, this particular Stardust clip. Yes. Yep. No, I disagree.
Waste of time. Yep. We did it.
It's not like Assan is Chud's Chud's now stretching this out.
So, we're going to watch this and then once he finishes this
rant, then all I have like 15 Nick messages from I think his
Discord that we'll go through and then we can cover those. So,
we need to check this out. Love this. And I've, you know, thinking
idiot. I think so. Can you hear this? Can you hear the video,
Kelly, when I hit play? Yes. Jesus. Okay, perfect. Just I literally
started speaking just as you and I, you know, think and you forget
there's a delay. But it just feels like at the moment it's anything
that goes delay. Oh my god, it's not that. Okay, but if I've
started if I've started speaking and the video is going on, I
assume that you're going to press stop when I'm speaking, but
apparently the video is more important. Well, I'm just trying
to get you the context you wanted, Kelly. That's all. No, cuz
you could have done that. Well, I didn't I haven't even read
the messages yet, you know. I haven't even read them yet. I'm
getting to them slowly over time.
Yep. Yep. Yep. As a lefty idiot, whatever. Right. But it just
feels like at the moment anything that goes against Assan. Anything
that goes against Assan is uh you know is is considered worthy
of support. Okay, that's wonderful. But how do I make money off
depressed people? The cheese wheel became a member. The cheese
wheel celebrates 10 months of membership. Go off chy buddy. FK
regarded wars and politics over dirt and religion. Thank you
Cheese Wheel for the membership. Wow. Now I'm not bringing up
Nicholas Dorio's stream. I'm not making it about any one individual.
I care about your gay c. This is also really You know what? You
know what? Whilst we're uh Oh, is he going to get really mad
that uh you going to get mad about the creek? Is that Is Chud
gonna Is Chud going to denounce the creek right now? Although
I think they've changed the name. I saw Apr's title yesterday.
Either Queman's or I can't remember. They changed the name. I'll
also say this as well. I'm so sick. Oh, I see. Ape Creek can
go in a Ape Creek can go in a YouTube title, right, and not get
the stream demonetized. Yes, I got it. It's okay. You know what?
Can you give me a TDR for why
I don't I've not read yet, so I have to watch the rest of this
rant and then I can start. I don't mean that. For [__]
sake. I mean this stream. What
Chud uh so there's something going on here and for some reason
Ch Oh, Chud says, "I'm only interested in this because it's dry
as the desert. It's dry as a bone out in the desert of drama
land. Unless you want to go and suck off Ethan Klein." And then
he said, "I'm talking to you, Nicholas Doro." And then he went
on this rant about the ADL and how Ethan sucks. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. So, he's been on this rant for a while and we're doing
it. You know what? Whilst we're here, I'll also say this as well.
I am so [__] sick of you utter cretins desperately
trying to [__] throw a wedge between me and Dioro
because he's [__] sucking Ethan clone at the moment.
Okay, I [__] have got my issues with it. But you
guys are so [__] you're like my brain with this [__]
It's [__] unbelievable. Dude, if you got a problem
saying hold on ri donated $3 all my neighbors on that wage between
you and Nicholas. If you've got a problem with something that
Creman is saying, that is between you and Creman. I'm talking
broadly about the issue that exists that I've noticed and you
are trying to laser focus in on one person cuz you want to start
some beef. Okay? Listen, at the end of the day, it's not Listen,
if you've got a problem with what someone else is saying, go
and speak to them about it. Go to the Don't Brigade them. Go
to their stream. Go to If you're one of the rare people that's
unblocked by Nicholas on Twitter, okay? going. Why do you have
to keep Okay, he Do you see this little subtle game he plays?
Okay, Chud is way more way more malicious than he'll ever let
on. He didn't have to do that right there, did he? Did he have
to do that? Did he have to go and call Nicholas a sensitive little
right there, but without saying it directly? But it's it's overt
to me. I can hear it. I can hear. He says, "Well, if you're one
of the few people who isn't blocked by Nicholas on Twitter,"
and what he said there is, "If you're not if you Nicholas is
a sensitive little, but if you can get a message to him," that's
what he said. Oh, I just muted it. Whoops. By Nicholas on Twitter,
okay, go and tweet him. I don't care about your personal individual
issues with another creator. Okay? This is not about any one
person. This is about a culture that has been cultivated that
I would even say I somewhat participated in. I did criticize
Ethan Klein for some things. Okay. But I definitely was, you
know, alongside criticizing the CPS stuff because I thought it
was so. Okay, that's wonderful. But how do I make monstous people?
Are you blocked by Nick? No, I think I'm followed by Nick. I
don't I didn't really I don't really have a problem with Nick.
My problem with Nick Dick is mostly that um he agreed to talk
to me after giving like some really bad review of one of my streams
or some commentary I made on Willie. He agreed to talk to me
and then he refused to talk to me after that. That that frustrated
me when he did that, right? Cuz he was like he he made a whole
bunch of negative commentary and then I was like, "Oh, do you
want to talk?" And he was like, "Yeah, I'll come on and talk."
And then he like told uh Smaggle that he'd come on and talk.
And then he was like, "Actually, no, I'm not going to come on
and talk." And no, I don't want to talk to you at all anymore.
And I think that's mostly just proximity to uh Queen. I I think
that had nothing to do with me. It just mostly had to do with
being like proximal to Queen and stuff when Quumman was going
off about some of the things. What did Queman do? Uh, Queen's
all of Nicholas's friends one by one. What does that I told Nick
that the first time I ever met him and I told him that pretty
much every time I met him after that. There's nothing he can
do about it. What friends and how is he them?
Uh, because they can't handle uh they can't handle criticism.
Yep. Who? And what criticism? What does that mean? Don't worry
about it, Kelly. It'll become apparent over time. Okay. It will
become apparent over time. Why are you so annoying? just to answer
a question.
You are not a subtle creature and I am a subtle creature. Okay.
I'm more than what's the point of being. You got like one hammer
in your toolbox. I don't have a hammer. So, I'm going to make
little I'm going to make little comments and you want me to just
scream at who I'm like you want me to scream out what I want
to do. No, that's not me. Okay. We don't do it like that. Yeah.
I have a big hammer and I'll smash you around the ed with it
if you don't just spit it out. Yeah, that's okay. We're more
subtle here, Kelly. No, we're not. It's a drama channel, not
a being channel. I know. Well, we need to be subtle in this case.
Okay. Why? Why do we I literally went to like five different
servers to call Nicholas Dioro fat. What subtle is this? Which
I disavowed, by the way. She called me fat, too, Nick. Okay,
we could we could start a support group. I promise we'll be okay.
Okay. Oh, I see. We're throwing Kelly under the bus, are we?
No. Did you not call Did you not call me fat, Kelly? Did you
not call me fat Kelly? I'm sensitive, you know. Okay, I'm sensitive
and you you hurt my feelings. So now you're a lot and also I
me and Nick. Okay, I'm getting in the Iron Dome. Okay, Nick,
I say you're fat. I'm hopping in the Iron Dome. Protect me with
the belly. Protect me with the iron stomach. Nick,
please. Protect me from the British people. Protect He kind of
looks like how Cartman would be if Cartman was a real person.
Ah, you're so mean.
It's accurate. Jtock ignoring our let Kelly speak redeems. I
don't have it up. Wait, is there a lot of Let Kelly speak right
now? Maybe I should be letting Kelly speak because my bad. Venomous
villages donated for it. Doro Iron Dome. The Oreo's Iron Dome.
Is this Stop with the clip of him eating pie. It's so up. It's
not that funny. And eating it, too. Now you can't unsee it. Why
are you guys so Yeah, I mean, unfortunately that the the Cartman
uh comparisons do make sense, but why why can't we just be nice?
Why can't we just be nice to this guy, Kelly? Uh he started it.
Okay, well, a little bit and I will always finish it. Okay, I
will end him. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. By the way, it says
this is cake. This is like lemon mering pie. Clearly, it's like
flipped over lemon merang pie. I'm almost positive this is like
mering up here. All right, batting. Oh, it's on a loop. I see.
I got it. I got it. I got it. Okay.
Nick, she's got Look, hold on. I'll pull it up. Uh rile kitten
house.
Yeah. What are you doing? Helix. Uh spiral to both of us. Okay.
Spiraling
twist. I think spiraling. Why is your name not in here? Fat.
Oh, you are there. Never mind. Yourself. You loser.
Soed up. It's soed up. So, Nick, message me. I need I need support
in this moment. Okay. She calls you fat. She calls me fat. It's
It's [__] up. I need I need a friend right now. But
thank you for the super chat. But the Sorry. Anyway, I forget
I forget where we were going with any of that or how I ended
up where we ended up. But all that being said, but but the reality
is that yes, there are absolutely issues with how Ethan has been
going about things and there's been this unending support for
the guy every turn and it's just a bad ass bad ass bad and it's
very
boring. Is bad. Oh my god, he's Oh my god, he's saying it. Han
is bad.
That play go.
Oh, I hit mute again. Han is bad though. But hold on. Hassan
is bad, but he's not that bad anyway. He's not Asthma bad. I
see. Okay, that's wonderful. But how do I make money
off the contents of the screenshot? Yeah. He told me he was like
half an hour ago. Yeah, I did share it with you. Still going.
Okay, that's wonderful. I don't think I've got that many people
watching me after me asking for 20 and I have no context. So,
yeah. Well, I'm getting the context at the same time you are,
Kelly. We're going. Yes. Very slowly. Depressed people. Okay.
Ch seems to be waiting for a bunch of donations. I would like
to do the same. Guys, if you want to get out of the way, if you
want to start donating now early at the start of the stream,
okay, you can donate. Okay, you can donate through Streamlabs.
You can donate through Kickbot. You can sub through kick. You
can give me your Twitch Prime. Twitch primers should be up, guys.
Go over to twitch.tv/jdk with an underscore. Throw your Twitch
Prime at me over there. All right. Throw your Twitch Prime at
me over there. 10 minutes. Can we get on with Streamlabs. Streamlabs
and kickbot exclamation point. Donate in the chat. We'll give
you the links for both of them. Okay, they'll give you for both
of them. And I'm not even going to I'll just say that the Patreon
exists. patreon.com/jastk if you guys want to go there cuz I
don't want to chill for too long cuz Kelly is busy. Okay, she
got to go to bed. Cloudy became a member. Glad cleared up. So,
what's your thoughts on Destiny? Wonderful. But how do I make
money off depressed people? Riy Weird became a member. It's your
favorite.
But how do I the dude? How many times can you West became a member?
The latest thing about his ban, dude. Bro, the latest thing about
his ban, bro. That was that was I didn't I make money after that
was very that was very Oh, there's new Assant Assan got banned
and I think I said well he's probably going to get banned for
like a day and that would be it. And that happened he got banned
for a day and then he got put back on. How many times can you
talk about how bad Twitch Oh, Twitch supports crazy content.
Yes, we've known that today. We known that last year too became
a member. They've previously done other crazy as well that at
the time was somewhat interested to talk about at the time it
was somewhat interested to talk about a Twitch loves terrorism.
Broom became a member. Yes. I'm going to have to mute these things.
It's distracting me. How many more times do you need to How many
more times do you need to make the same point that Twitch is
dog, man? It's so It's so ridiculous. It's so ridiculous, bro.
Okay, he's stretching this out into a segment. I'm going to use
a bathroom real quick. I'll be right back. It is so obscene how
it just this endless attention and focus, you know, endless attention
and focus talking about what a what what a terrible platform
Twitches and oh Assan said of the crazy on stream and he got
banned for a day. The happy birthday thing Twitch did was cringe.
Yeah, it was when it happened what 6 months ago at this point.
I mean, bro, it's one thing to like fondly remember some drama
that happened, but like, dude, we're getting ridiculous with
this, aren't we? I'm just genuinely very tired. But unless I
say something like 20 times, no one ever listens to me. So, has
generational crash out. If it's a crash out, so be it. Okay,
if this is a crash out, so be it. If you want I just want to
say that no matter what. I'm so sorry to do this cuz you know
we love we love a certain um middle-aged guy here who's not Ethan.
Okay, we love that guy. But if Chad doesn't want to call out
the architect of all of this, the guy who is spreading JN far
and wide to to everybody he can. If he doesn't want to actually
call out the root cause, then I don't think he's actually mad
about this. I don't think he's he's not saying the name. Say
the name, Chud. Say the name. I don't I don't get it. Who's he
supposed to be calling out? And for what? And for why? I don't
know why he's really that mad. I don't get Who's the architect
of the Twitch anti-semitism stuff? Who's pushing Ethan to to
lose his mind? Who's pushing all of the Hassan bad stuff, Kelly?
Who is it? Oh, say the name. Say the name. Any of that matter?
I don't understand what this rant's about. Really? That's okay,
Kelly. That's basically most of the stuff we talk about. It's
fine. You don't like what I got to say? I literally said I'd
only been here like half an hour ago. You've been watching this
for a lot longer. But you know the name, but you're not playing
into it, so it's fine. Okay, but why? I can't play into something
when I don't really know what's going on. Uh, so I said Chud's
clearly not that mad about it if he's not going to call out the
primary contributor, the primary architect of this entire thing.
Right. Anyway, that's fine about what I've got to say. So be
it. I'll have that conversation. Okay. It's just it's at what
point does it stop, man? At what point does this endless attention
and focus on this drama end? You know, I just I don't get I don't
get it. I don't get probably never ends as long as you don't
identify the root cause of the drama. I don't know how people
can still be talking about Twitch bad and it's still up so much
oxygen of the conversation, you know. And it even got to the
point, dude, it's even gotten to the point, okay, it's even gotten
to the point where Creator Clash 3 got the the drama and the
discussion about that got subsumed got [__] subsumed
by Ethan and Assan and and that that [__] drama cycle,
it got subsumed by it and that's what it all became about. The
[__] gay cold war between Hassan and Ethan and it
all became about that, right? rather than being like, "Oh, Ian
and I'm going to say even if Chud doesn't say it, this is Chud's
rant against his former friend Dan Saltman." Okay, I don't know
why Chud had to come for Dan's neck like this like so out in
the open. I I feel like Dan has to respond, right? Like Chud
Chud has just come for Dan Saltman like directly with all of
this. We're failing again. It's Ethan and Nissa are failing,
Ethan. And that's good. And that's good actually. So, you're
not going to do messages anytime soon, then? I have no idea.
Right. It's not fun to talk about. There's no point being here.
I don't know why you like That's fine, Kelly. That's fine. That's
fine. That's fine. I can I can go if we're not going to It's
fine. I'll go over it. You can watch it tomorrow, but I'm going
to go over it in order. Okay.
Oh, so this time you want to do it in order. Any other time you're
absolutely happy to just around and go in and out of a bunch
of I'm actually enjoying this segment. I want to do it. So, if
you're going to just kind of disrupt, I am fine with leaving
if that's what you It's not disrupting. I came on to talk about
the same thing talking about now. Okay. But I told you that I
hadn't watched the segment. I had no idea it was going this long.
So, it's fine. I can go.
Why would you go? I'd obviously go. I don't know why you keep
saying I'm going to go. I just like I wanted like like No, I
said I was tired and you just That sucks. I'm sorry that I didn't
realize how long it was going to go. That's my bad. I did tell
you like 5 minutes and I thought it was going to be fast, but
it's not. So now I' we've identified that it's not. I have no
idea how much longer it's going to go. The rest of the messages
are way right now, but I can I can send it to you when I'm done.
Why can't you? We're taking like two seconds. I If somebody wants
to Ra, if you want to send it to her, you can go ahead. Whatever
then. Okay. Are useless. See you later. And are failing again.
It's Oh, Ethan and Na are failing. Seriously, I want people to
understand that when you hop on the stream, I am like basically
sitting. It's like you went to the DMV and your friend works
at the DMV and like I still have to push people through the line,
right? So, you can come up and you can say hi, but like you can't
just totally obstruct me actually doing my job. You know what
I'm saying? Like it's fine that you're here and hey, I'm at work
and and stuff. And I know you work here at the DMV, too, and
sometimes we actually work together, but like if you just aren't
going to like obstruct what I'm actually doing, that's not helpful
because they've attacked Ethan. And that's good. And that's good,
actually. I just it's so obnoxious, bro. It's not fun to talk
about. It's not fun to get into. Also, and you are also responsible
for this as well, chat. You are also responsible for this, too.
So, don't think you're getting awayly with this, okay? You guys
have made it so unpleasant to talk about any of this as well
because you've turned it into like serious political discourse.
Okay? I don't give two about Israel Palestine at the end of the
day. Right? beyond streaming. Yes, I've got some sort of, you
know, personal polit Okay, I'm getting one guy from the chat.
I already said to you guys, I said to Kelly, "Hey, uh, my bad.
I didn't realize how long this was going to go." So, I said,
"My bad. My bad. I didn't realize how long it was going to go.
So, I'm going to go like, uh, I'm going to finish the segment
and then we'll go over it at the end of the segment once we're
done with the the Chud stuff." And then she's asking me how long
it's going to go. And I just said to you, I said, "I'm I'm sorry
that it's going to go longer. I don't know how long this is.
So, at that point, it's like she knows exactly she knows exactly
what the issue is, right? And and then she just keeps bringing
it up on the stream. It's interesting in it. I don't think people
dying is good or whatever, right? But the stakes have been risen
to this ridiculous level with it, you know, and everything is
underpinned now by this Israel Palestine. And that also is just
ruining it too. It's just ruining the whole thing, bro. drama
centered all the time constantly around this issue. It's too
much. It's too much that it's constantly in the background of
all the drama. That's the Israel Palestine stuff. I understand
that it's like being subsumed in or is being um a part of this
a little bit, but it's more I feel like it's more anti-semitism.
Like it's more Israel Palestine kind of looms over anti-semitism,
but realistically Ethan and Hassan their discussions on Israel
Palestine are like kind of laughable. They're just dog [__]
So I don't know. You can say it's about that, but realistically
neither of them know the conflict all that well and they're mostly
just getting like pointers from other people. It's happening
at the moment. You know, we need to separate out. We need to
separate out the politics from the drama content again and get
back to mindless Kelly saying this is about messaging. She hopped
on the stream. She was interrupting me on the stream. She could
have just messaged [__] [__] to drama,
whatever it is. Yep. You know, rather than bang on
rather than bang on constantly about, you know, a drama topic
that is linked to this more serious subject. And here's the thing
that Chud's not going to get into because again he doesn't want
to insult people. But this also leads to you especially when
you tie the politics to it in some superficial way let's say
okay even when you do that and you tie the politics to it and
you tie like this big drama to it. Now when Idubbbz is holding
that sword and nobody should really care you have to make that
sword the end of the world right every single issue is the end
of the world. It's just another example of overt and blatant
anti-semitism that these people can't go a day without doing
right. And it's like, no, it's not. No, it's not. It's actually
not that big a deal. But you have to make it a big deal. You
have to make it the next big thing. And unfortunately, there's
just a ton of money in doing that in getting people amped up
and and continue to see how like evil these people are. Yeah.
It's just a sidesc know about the serious subject. So all you
can do is talk about the drama, but you need a fundamental analysis
alongside each other of both to really contextualize and explain
what's going on properly
a little bit. Thank you for the super chats by the way. I did
mute alerts while I'm ranting. I think
$5 here. If this guy can't acknowledge that Twitch is infested
with anti-semitism, he must be added to the watch list. I have
no doubt that I will be doxed by stop anti-semitism at some point.
Okay. I have no doubt it's going to happen. So, you're saying
Oreo is singing for Ethan to make the J money? Wow. Wow.
Wow. No, I don't think it's I actually don't think it's people.
I think it's like mostly I think it's mostly white people who
are watching this and consuming it. And I don't know if I don't
know if people they're like way too industrious of people. They
ain't got time to watch every Nick Dioro stream. Okay. But I
like there there is anti-semitism that happens. Hassan did do
like some really bad. The terrorism stuff was bad. that needed
to be addressed. I was fully on board with like this guy and
Twitch for like letting this go. When they kidnapped those people
off that boat and Hassan's just like this is awesome and no punishment
comes. That's up. But realistically, they changed some policies.
They talked to the ADL. They like did a whole bunch of things
and then on the other side like they came out and I assume they
weren't going to allow it to happen again. U Matt NLT, thank
you very very much for the tier 2 on Twitch. Thank you. Thank
you. Appreciate it, buddy. I was a Nick fan until the Destiny
Defending Willie Max video is cringe. Um I mean Nick Nick is
really funny. Nick is really really
Yeah, but I I just think like unfortunately you get you get yourself
whipped up into a fervor over this stuff and you can make like
anything they do bad. And some of it was just like it was just
over the line, right? Like it's just the the sword stuff was
just like bro I think this is crazy. And then what came after
the sword stuff? the skulls were like like trying to blame that
on like Hassan or that whole crew in some way, right? And I think
in any other case with like somebody like Bad Empanada, people
go just don't give them attention, right? But in this case, because
everybody's whipped into a frenzy, we got to give Bad Empanada
all this attention as well.
So, in other words, a private for-profit company has to make
money. So, they need to suck off their golden boy within some
basic. Well, oh, sorry, fell pow. That's going into some of the
Hassan stuff. That is what happened with Han. Yeah. Yeah, I'm
just it's like I don't know. It it just it has to all be it has
to be important. So you got to take these little tidbits and
say like this is obviously and it's like the sad thing is is
like completely predictable tidbits like when when Denims goes
live and like talks some it's all predict it's all totally predictable.
Nobody's shocked that Denims went live and talks some Nick is
late into Destiny though. Yeah. I think um I don't know what
Ironside's talking about. I have no criticism of Nick's opinions
on Destiny or anything he's done there. Um, I appreciate Nick
actually going as hard as he did on that. I totally I'm totally
fine with everything Nick said about the Destiny. I'm totally
fine with Nick criticizing me on the Destiny if that's what he
wants to do. Like I I don't really have any any problem with
any of his coverage there at all. Uh, it's mostly just been this
stuff. But again, I I feel like I got sort of a preview of it
because I was on um I was like on on his uh I was like in that
role of like chief anti-Han propagandist for a while. So, I got
to I got to see what it was like. Okay. I know how effective
it is. He's not a like Willie Mac. Well, no, he's not. Anyway,
we continue. Okay. But yeah, it's, you know, it's it's a lot
of the drama has just been subsumed by this greater issue, greater
conflict and whatnot. And yeah, just kind of sucks. Just kind
of sucks. It's boring to talk about. So, yeah. Uh, but the problem
becomes is that obviously it is overbearing of all other drama
and I've not been interested in getting into it, but then it
touches everything. So you can't really avoid it. And then when
you do avoid it and you're not wanting to talk about it because
it's boring. He did that whole J talk is making it all about
himself. Well I So what I would say there Captain Capy events
is like I went on that stream that Willie was on. I hadn't like
practiced anything. I had like written anything down. I just
I was like oh we're talking about this and I went and talked
right. It's not like I had some dissertation that I'd like distilled
down to something uh you know well that was like great to speak
about. And when I when I said like, "Oh, you could have reached
out to me." Like that probably was a mistake, but I'm like totally
fine with calling it a mistake. And I went on stream and called
it a mistake after that. I said, "Oh, I shouldn't have said that.
That's probably the incorrect thing to say." But nobody really
they didn't care. It seems like uh Willie clipped the stream
where I said that a whole bunch of times. He clipped that and
put it into his most recent video, but he didn't look at any
of those clips. So like realistically, they just showed me that
like, oh, with these people, like if you give them charity, they
won't care about that at all. they'll they'll just keep going
after you, right? So, realistically, I don't think I have to
it's like to to give them charity. I have no idea if that means
anything, right? To be to be like nice or to be honest and like
I messaged Willie a couple times. I've never gotten a message
back from him, I don't think. I think I've messaged him like
a couple times and just said like, "Hey, um you want to squash
the beef?" And then, "Hey, I'm reaching out one more time and
just literally like, "Hey, I uh just I I wouldn't mind squashing
this beef. Like, I don't think it's really that big a deal."
No answer any of those three times. Uh I realize I was correct,
Cam the Jellyman. I realized I was correct, but uh it is what
it is. Isn't being nice its own reward? Maybe. I think it it
just works out as in like if they'd wanted to talk to me, it
wouldn't have been a big deal, right? For them to be But I think
both of them being like, "No, we'll never talk to you again."
Then it's like, "Well, hold on. Why wouldn't you if I'm just
like a Why wouldn't you just talk to me and like mock me anyway?
It's all fine." and endlessly discuss whatever the Yeah, I know
what you're saying, Bussyo. Stupid Ethan is doing or what dumb
[__] Asana said on stream, you know? There's just
not much else going on because everything is getting subsumed
into this one central drama, you know? Uh yeah, drama 101. But
unfortunately, I said Lily should have reached out to me and
that was like the thing they latched on to and I think I think
I did exactly the right thing there. I just was like, "Oh, I'll
stop I'll stop like talking. I'll back off of this entirely."
And then that was the only thing they've ever latched on to from
that. not really defended against any of the other criticisms
at all or like talked about any of the other criticisms at all,
right? They just talk about me and I think it makes them look
absurd to anybody who's informed, but not a lot of people are
informed. So, I don't know. It is what it is. So, anyway, that's
what I think about that. Any questions? Any questions? Any questions?
I was just trying to stretch this out to 15 minutes. We We're
almost at the the message. All of this after going on about how
dry drama is. Talk about it or don't, but the endless ranting
is gay. Well, I think I think that chat would probably disagree
and I think you're probably quite entertained by that ranting
there. I don't get, dude, it's not about it's not about Chad
throws shade at you during this stream. Uh, Chud just banters.
Chud, that's again I'd be perfectly happy to talk to Chud. I
think um and I'm sure he has real criticisms, but I think a lot
of the times he's just doing the same thing Nick does a lot of
the time. Okay. Where he's like he's going to do that thing.
That's fine. Starter, Steven, right? It's about an atmosphere
that's been created and I you know I'll put my hands up and say
yeah sure I I at times participated in that if if you want to
say that. I don't you know I don't want to be like oh I I you
know I said things about Ethan I I defend anything because I
thought it was right to do so at the time. You know the CPS call
was obviously deranged and there's obviously other things that
have happened that are over a line and insane. But there's just
this this this narrative that Ethan is like beyond reproach and
it's just not true. Like Ethan has definitely done derange [__]
as well. You know, it's like a uh it's like two people. It's
like two people stabbing each other at the same time. It feels
like I want to hear about the rain people or skits blacks, but
what you can find is the latest Ethan or Idubbbz said. Yep.
So scrutinizes narratives and criticizes people who follow them
uncritically.
Okay. Exactly. It is all consuming. It is just it's it's uh you
know overbearing. It's very overbearing and frustrating. And
you know, you kind of just got to find what you can. and we found
some good stuff to talk about, but obviously this particular
content today has not really been up to up to the right level
for me to not just spur out for a bit.
So anyway, I think I think that's all I got to say about that
to be honest. Listen, I'm in a great mood. I'm in a great mood.
Okay, that was very uh very very night very good. Very good to
just have a spur out. My streams are a mess. I was trying to
see if we're done.
I am happy. I'm happy now,
but uh there we go. Someone someone my pants this morning. Yeah,
it's probably the energy drinks to be honest. All right, we'll
speed up a little bit. I think we're basically done. I'll turn
I'll turn on thingies as well. I turn them off. I need to get
out of that. Well, no. I just hope I hope that some of the stuff
start to dissipate and some new fresh stuff comes to the forefront.
Sh I'm not bored of drama. I love talking about drama. I love
talking about creating [__] that's happening. What
I don't like is endlessly looping about the same people and the
same topics all time and it's been that way for months and months
now. Okay, let's go. You said this eight times.
There we go. Find a new comment. Find any new comment. Yeah,
dude. Like this be like when did this first start? October 2023.
October 2023 is when it started. And there's been a number of
times where I've been like, "Okay, dude. I'm this is going, you
know, something else happens." And at some point I just like, "Yeah,
I've got off. I can't just
so Ianina said it in the chat." Actually, actually say the name.
Say the real name. Say the real name. Okay, Chud.
Cast off your shackles for real and say the real Say the name.
Stop saying Ethan Hassan Destiny. Okay. Say the name. Say the
actual name. It's Ethan. Yes, exactly. Okay, that's wonderful.
But how do I make money off the press table? Just stop because
the rant was spot on rise up. Thank you. He won't he won't name
the software CEO. Okay. He won't name him. Name him. Name him.
Name name him. Chuds.
I'm this uh Dan, I'm sorry, Dan, if you're actually watching
this, Dan. Okay, this is mostly It just happens that these memes
line up. It's really up actually. Okay, Jesus Christ. It's up.
Okay, that's wonderful. But how do I make money? I'm trying to
chill. I'm trying to celebrate membership. The whole drama is
kind of the You get to When you get to the Why would you name
Why would you call him out? Why would you name the
conflict? One side can do no other side. Get a little edgy here.
But how do I make money off friendly Jordies bully the list mentally
disabled man today. Shared in Discord if you want something different.
I'm biased but funny drama emo. Okay, that's wonderful. But how
do I make money off me? I celebrates 13 months of membership.
Racism smiley face emoji. Thank you guys for support. Appreciate
it. Um yeah, sure. We take a look at that. There's one more thing
I want to look at this before we move on. One more quick thing
to look at and then we'll move on. Apparently he ran from this
this interview. the camera before. Okay. Well, I guess that I
somebody said he talks about me in this stream. I was trying
to find it, but I can't. So, oh well. I think that is basically
it. Not beating the allegations right now. Uh oh, what did it
say? Please, please be careful. Oh, right. Flag. Wink wink. Nudge
nudge. The guy was Dan is pro-Israel. Bad empanada. Well, you
know what? If that narrative is catching on, I don't know where
that came from, Dan. I certainly have never compared you to bad
empanada. I certainly wasn't the first person to do that. I certainly
didn't go out on a limb to make that comparison. Okay. So, if
Dan is watching right now, just know that I didn't do that. Okay.
Anyway, we gay makes a joke about you making it all about yourself.
You're covering the camera drama and Chud repeats it and goes
true. Oh, well, I expect that kind of commentary. Again, that's
so that would be most of the time Chud is is like quote unquote
talking me. Uh he's just getting that from other people, right?
He's just bantering. if if he actually watched something and
he was like making that that comment like deeply, but he does
that about other people. And unfortunately, that's just the way
you sort of like make it as a streamer is you you take your wins
where you can. People who don't understand that, I think just
um I'm sure I'm almost positive you'd have to be able to find
uh like clips of Chud doing it, but he calls other other people
out for doing it. Yeah, I watched him do it to like two days
ago. Like I was I was watching something with in it, listening
to Chud, and Chud like paused and was like, "It's not all about
you. Just not only did the whole rant, right? Continue. Oh, true.
Okay, we're done with that. Uh, do we have Oh, the screenshots.
Hold on. No, no, no. We're going to the screenshots, guys. Now,
Nicholas Dero heard this. Okay. Is happening on Chud's stream?
Apparently, he's just ripping into me, Connor, and Auggie. Lol.
I clicked on it and saw this donut, which blows my mind. Is anyone
shocked I agreed with a video that was an essay rip of all my
own arguments slapped into an easily digestible package? I love
Nicholas, but you are so real for this. Him seal clapping at
Cameron's blatant attempt to butter him up made me want to do
the needful. These rants and chat banter are the reason I spend
more money on donating to you than I did on hard drugs.
Okay. All right. I have literally told people who aren't interested
to go watch Chud funny enough. Like when people are tired of
what I'm interested in, I still send them to him. Lol. See, I
think I think Nicholas needs to understand like I Chud's stuff
is Chud when he when he like talks, it's usually like I don't
think Chud spends a ton of time. He spends a ton of time setting
up his stream, watching stuff on his stream. If you don't see
him watching your stuff on stream and he says stuff about you,
he's mostly getting those comments from other people, I think.
Right. And so, you should just see it as banter. He's just leaning
into banter with his chat and stuff, right? So, Nicholas, I don't
think Chud's watched a bunch of Nicholas's content on stream.
He's just going to lean into some of the jokes his chat are saying
about Nicholas because it's funny and it, you know, it's a it's
like literally just being an entertaining streamer. Okay. I don't
think he was doing like solid hardcore critique of Nicholas.
He was just going, "Oh, this is something people are saying about
Nicholas. Well, it's funny. Roll it in." Right. I Yeah, sorry.
Becket's video was good, but yeah, before that all you had was
a bias hit piece without I haven't seen it yet, but yeah, my
segment was partially promotion for that video, which hadn't
come out. Okay, let's see. We don't have the previous messages.
Judge strikes me as a bit overly concerned about the internal
politics of blank. Well, his chat just baits him to argue with
me all day. Again, I'm I'm pretty sure it's just like I said
here, right? I think it's just like I don't think it's real criticism.
Chat just baits him to argue with me all day. Looks like you
should have stuck to the friendship applications close thing.
Lol. After the fif last 50 interpersonal dramas, lol. I've just
focusing on me and my stream thing for the last year. So, I more
or less have. Yeah, I I kind of get it. He feels like when he
gets he feels like he's under attack from people. I can feel
this sometimes. It's mostly like I don't know, not real. Like
I think I think Chud would take banter back the other way. You
know what I'm saying? Also, I think it's been like like four
months ago Nicholas was in my server still and like hang out
all the time. I don't know. Is the back on? I don't care particularly.
I I like feel some amount of empathy here that he feels like
he's being attacked by Chud, right? I watch I watch Chud make
like little swipes at me and I'm like, "Oh, that's annoying,
right?" Right. But I'm again I think he would take swipes back
the other way. It's like whatever. Like you you have that moment
of like oh is this guy like coming from my head and then it's
like oh no he's just memeing. Right. I'm just saying I empathize
with that. Oh somebody says something bad about you. Like oh
is that guy coming from my head? No. Like basically never right.
Totally true gun. No. Stop. Nick knows. Nick should know better.
Especially cuz like Chud is I think Chud and Nick are like closer
than like I've talked to Chud like three times in DMs. So, like
for me it's like I I don't have a rapport with him really. Um
I have a rapport with Queenman, so I mostly think Chud's fine,
but Nick does have a rapport with him. Nick does know that like
like I don't know. I would say if Chud's going to make criticisms
of you too, he's probably not going to say something that's totally
without any basis, right? I would guess evil. Uh evil Johnny
Bravo, thank for the gifted sub. I don't know if that was to
Riyle, but thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Uh Nick said he saved
Chud's career. I know he did. I know he did. I know. I tried.
Okay. Well, when was the last time Dero was on Chud? I don't
know. I uh Chud likes to argue with chat, but let's be honest,
Chud loves a video that agrees with his blank his takes or something.
I just thought the donut was weird because they weren't my old
takes. They were my takes from two weeks ago. Hold on. Uh oh,
I skipped one. I skipped one. I skipped one. I skipped one. Oh,
no, I didn't skip one. Oh, I'm missing one, aren't I?
I feel like I'm missing one here, but
Uh, Space Coast, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it.
Appreciate
Uh, just my old takes. Nick, you should be more deeply involved
with Gup Shadow's small controversies that uh, blank blank blank
blank blank. The best part of those situations is the deep research
necessary coupled with the easy to miss parts and the six 40
plus minute group streams of five plus people who have mics that
are required reading. The 10,000 total VOD views make the whole
experience more worth the entire stream. I'd need to dedicate
to it. The whole experience more worth more than I think he's
just saying that it takes too long to get into the some of the
smaller stuff. Okay, sure. Uh, and it would be like Israel Palestine.
They will eat you apart for the uh the sec you missed a 15 POV.
Willie Max show must cover Kelly Jean. So, it's like again,
um, I I just think that this that the whole Destiny video thing
with Willie like soured their view on a lot of stuff. And I think
there was some good criticis criticisms there, some bad criticisms
there, but it really soured like their view on just like collaborating
with people, which is a bit weird. But, um, commentary YouTubers
and criticism, name a worse duo. It's like, dude, I don't know.
I don't know. I feel like I'm fine with feel like people criticize
me all the time and I just go, "Oh, whatever." I don't know.
Like I I expected when I had that argument with Willy Mack, like
to me it was like that was an argument we had and we could like
leave that in the past and it like doesn't matter. Like I had
a I had a way bigger argument with Aiden on stream. Uh Aiden
Underground or I think it's Aiden Underground is the stream,
but I had a way bigger argument with him that I had with either
Nick or Willie. And Aid and I will just argue about whatever
whatever, right? And and it doesn't matter that we had like a
heated argument before or people talk or whatever. I just I don't
care. It's just like content. It's just fun to argue with people.
Nick doesn't need to clap. He's reached critical mass on his
solo streams. Yeah,
probably. But I I don't know. That just doesn't seem like that
big a deal. Willy Mack last I checked. I don't think so. There's
one moment that I perfectly timed here. What is this? Chud logic
calling him Mr. Girl. And what sort of response do you get when
you issue like I don't know like a little little criticism of
Destiny or you got a little disagreement? What sort of what's
the response you tend to get from that community? Would you say
me? Yeah, it's not great sometimes. Sometimes it's fine. Sometimes
it's not great. I'm sorry. I don't care Mr. Girl. DG is not nearly
as autistic as dark. Oh my god. Look at this classic tactic.
Make it sound like I'm Mr. Girl. So, why should we assume that
you're not compromised when Wow, this is the McMad video. I'm
probably not going to watch this. Mostly because I have no idea
if it's to appropriate for Twitch. I thought I saw some stuff
there. Yeah, that's uh that's sort of that reaction that Chud
was describing was how I felt when I criticized Willie's video.
I just I didn't think it was that big a deal. I was like just
rip I was like I literally came in I was just like ripping off
the cuff. I didn't expect people to get like mad about it. It
just But it turned into like a massive thing. Like I was dug
in. I immediately after the stream was like, "Yeah, actually
probably like probably was a little too harsh on my criticism
or something, but nobody cared anyway." So, I feel like yeah,
there's no no upside to to taking something back or trying to
be, you know, good faith with people like that. It is what it